let's get to it though as it relates to
the hard news coming out on this monday
the nfl never sleeps there's always
something happening there were six
vacancies when the day began
and now there are seven hey when they
say black monday they don't say which
monday shireen doug peterson out of a
job in philadelphia more than a week
after the season ended after multiple
conversations with owner jeffrey lurie
and obviously the reporting yesterday
from espn was real we had confirmed it
last night the eagles had no comment but
it was my understanding that laurie
through these ongoing conversations with
doug peterson wanted to know what
peterson's vision for the team was and
how the team was going to dramatically
improve and return to contenders status
it had to be a a major dismay for lori
when you think you've got all the pieces
in place to contend every year you don't
have to win the super bowl every year
but you contend every year to have it
fall apart as quickly as it did
and to have your faith shaken in your
coach's vision for the team
and they talked and they talked and they
talked and they ultimately realized that
they should no longer be talking to each
other
and mike moore is going to come out
about this situation but i do wonder how
much of it is over carson wentz and his
future in philadelphia and what the plan
is for carson wentz and whether doug
peterson disagreed with that plan and
you know there is a report out there
from espn that that their relationship
was would not be repairable at this
point and that was one of the things
that played into this and i know press
taylor their quarterbacks coach and
passing game coordinator was another
area of contemporary
and i think we have
a freeze there for sherine we'll get
serene back the notion that the
relationship between carson wentz and
jeffrey laurie was fractured beyond
repair i was a little bit skeptical
about that because i know what the
eagles plan is for carson wentz for 2021
they want to take some time they want to
get some distance from the season and
then they want to make a good decision
about who the quarterback will be to
start the 2021 season will it be wence
reinstalled will it be hertz
reinforced or will it be an open
competition to be determined based upon
how things go in the offseason program
training camp in the preseason to the
extent that peterson was an impediment
to that maybe he did have to go maybe
they need someone in there who can try
to strike the right relationship with
carson wentz to get him to choose to
stick around and that's going to be the
real question coming in you've got two
quarterbacks so usually a head coach
wants his own quarterback
whoever gets this job sharing is walking
into a place that has two quarterbacks
good news is
double the chance that it's a
quarterback the new coach is going to
want bad news is there's a chance the
new coach wants neither
yeah that's right mike and if you have
two quarterbacks as the old saying goes
you don't have one and i don't know that
anyone knows what the future of the
quarterback position is with the eagles
at this point it does depend a lot on
who they get but mike when you fire a
head coach right you you fire the head
coach because you think you can get
somebody better this is a head coach who
won a super bowl now i don't think based
on what's happened since frank reich
left
and that's number two we'll get shireen
back again apparently the football gods
do not want her commenting on the status
of the philadelphia eagles she makes a
great point though about
hiring a coach after you've fired a guy
when you make the decision you kind of
have an idea where you're going to go
does jeffrey lurie know where he's going
to go or is he just simply choosing the
devil he doesn't know over the devil he
does know and anybody will be better or
anybody that we find
through the unfolding of a careful and
deliberate thought process will be
better
if they do have a plan as to where
they're going to end up they've kept it
very quiet there's been no rumors no
reporting of any other candidates in
advance of peterson being fired but now
that peterson is out we have to be
curious as the search unfolds where it
lands and whether there's a pre-ordained
outcome we know the nfl prefers that
owners not have a pre-ordained outcome
they want an open and deliberate and
methodical and inclusive search
but we're talking about billionaires
here who are used to having their own
way and in many occasions when the
firing comes the owner knows exactly who
he's going to hire sometimes
that forced
deliberate quality to the search causes
the owner to change his mind it's still
believed that's what happened in 2007
with the pittsburgh steelers when all
signs were pointing to russ grimm is the
successor to bill cower and the
deliberate process resulted in mike
tomlin getting the job so with the
philadelphia eagles where does it go
from here a couple of the names that
immediately are rocketing to the top of
the list and there is
there is
offshore
oddsmaking that i've already seen and we
don't like to name offshore or really
any others than points back we'll see
what points bet has a a prop list of who
the next eagles coach will be but the
favorites i've seen so far are eric b
enemy the current head not head coach
the current offensive coordinator excuse
me of the chiefs and mike kafka a former
eagles quarterback who is the passing
game coordinator and quarterbacks coach
of the chiefs he's the guy who's caught
in the be enemy log jam because the i
graduated to philadelphia's head coach
after being chief's offensive
coordinator then it was matt nagy who
graduated being bears head coach after
being chief's offensive coordinator now
it's eric the enemy three years of
working with patrick mahomes he still
hasn't gotten a head coaching job the
idea is he graduates to a head coaching
position and then mike kafka becomes the
next guy in this pipeline who eventually
gets spit out into a head coaching job
maybe maybe kafka over takes the enemy
wouldn't that be something if he gets
hired for a head coach before be enemy
i hope it doesn't come to that because
there's something that's not right here
because if
if
if mike kafka was the better coach he'd
be the offensive coordinator not
the enemy in kansas city right
regardless
we'll see where it goes and how could
either guy not be attractive it's that
andy reid dna that still exists in
philadelphia now the one thing to
remember and teams do factor this into
their thought process you know with
peterson being fired could he end up
with the jets well
the jets just
fired a guy that they had hired right
after he was fired by another team
and
why would they hire somebody else who's
just been fired by another team
it's too similar to what you just did so
from the eagles perspective it's too
similar to raid andy reed's coaching
staff they just did it and it ultimately
didn't work of course after it did
so man
look it's gonna be a fascinating angle
does jeffrey lurie already want
or already know who he wants look at
that philly not so special three years
after winning the super bowl three years
three straight playoff appearances 2017
2018 2019
one year of not making it to the
postseason after three straight playoff
births and doug peterson is out it
really is amazing
and
if i'm the candidate for that job if i'm
in line for that
i want to know exactly what went haywire
here
because
whatever standard
applied to doug peterson is going to
apply to me at some point i'm going to
know exactly what doug peterson did to
get himself fired i saw a tweet for me
and rap before that doug peterson
basically was sick of telling of him of
people telling him what to do
that's called working for someone else
unless you own your own deal unless you
you you have your own business or are
the owner of some other business that
you've bought or whatever unless you're
sitting at the top of the pyramid
somebody's gonna be telling you what to
do and even then whatever whatever
business you're in your customers are
gonna tell you what to do the idea that
i don't want people telling me what to
do look i don't like people telling me
what to do
but there are certain times where i have
to acknowledge the fact that
people are going to tell me what to do
now if it's constant if it's unnecessary
if it's gratuitous if you feel like that
that the the person who's tell
qualifications or the knowledge
necessary to do so or if it's becoming a
distraction that's a different issue
altogether and who knows maybe there's a
story to be told at some point now
doug peterson has at least one year i
think it's one year left on his contract
maybe more there's a buyout in play so
don't look for doug peterson to tell a
bunch of stories and air out dirty
laundry if he wants to preserve his buy
out and i thought it was funny that
jeffrey lurie made it clear during a
press conference today he would advocate
the hiring of doug peterson by
another team of course he would he
doesn't want to have to pay the buyout
he wants to save some money you get a
dollar for dollar credit for any money
that doug peterson makes somewhere else
maybe he makes as much somewhere else
that really is the question
all these these jobs out there right now
six of them
will someone say stop the press
i want doug peterson it's happened in
recent years when
randy lerner then the owner of the
browns
was meeting with the media after he had
fired whoever the coach was at the time
and i can't remember frankly who the
coach was at the time
he was in the press conference and he
found out eric mangini was available
he'd just been fired by the jets at
browns like that and then when adam gase
was fired by the dolphins and became
available to the jets
the jets hire adam gase so it's possible
that somebody is going to say we'll take
the super bowl winning coach i mean
there there aren't many
super bowl winning coaches who are
available to be hired right now and
there are now
seven teams looking for jobs i assume
the eagles won't be hiring doug peterson
but the other six chargers falcons
jaguars jets lines texans who knows and
as of right now
the there's still a sense that urban
meyer
is going to ultimately decide thumbs up
and yes he's he's going in that
direction we may delve more deeply into
that later in the program
but you know the the
we're a week in
and typically what happens is once one
falls then there's an urgency
for the other teams to make their hire
and it really is fascinating and we do
this every year where
it's such an important decision
it's so critical to the future of a
franchise but but sometimes there's just
kind of a slipshod sense that you just
get to the point where we've talked to
enough people we've interviewed enough
somebody eventually we're gonna hire
somebody let's just hire this person and
be done with it so it can start at any
time and once the dominoes start to fall
they can fall in rapid succession and
buy by next monday all seven jobs in
theory could be filled i have a feeling
that we won't get all seven filled but
i'd be stunned if next monday we're
talking about none
being
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports